Maria's we come to fight we thoughtful
Bob we're life we are alive all right
all right we're live
welcome we are absolutely live welcome
to episode 300 and you ladies and
gentlemen this is a monumental situation
up took 300 this is 300 in the way it's
the Christian year 2000 that's exactly
right 18 by the new calendar by the new
calendar by the new calendar but it's
all that matters because is what people
cuz the corporation's celebrants why
write it the corporation's is also an
excellent calendar yeah I think I can
think of to corporations celebrate it
but we'll get to our sponsors so you are
you you prefer the Christian calendar
over what other calendars are out there
yes well with the Chinese calendar
what is it the Jewish calendar oh then
it was New Year's yesterday yeah you
know maybe this is our New Year's
episode Neil deGrasse Tyson says Ari's
New Year re Happy New Year except for
that have you year happy G what years in
due time five billion happy year five
billion you [ __ ] Jew race traitor why
is he a race trainer because these [ __ ]
non-jews that's oh I didn't know Jew is
a race Ari tell them race for who can
get more money am i right
am i right they're winning it but
they're winning that aisle by a longshot
they are they really are ari what's new
dude oh how are those how's that crap
what we call crap [ __ ] whoa crowd the
crowd [ __ ] are you throwing yourself in
that goddamn shitty river in between
Manhattan and Brooklyn and taking a nice
hot steamer or do you [ __ ] in a toilet
again now I just shouldn't wear this now
it's too boring boring boring boring Ari
like does your [ __ ] just flow red now
is it almost like a weird horror flick
you know
oh hey Ari where you gonna be no yeah oh
look at Erin you're fast buddy you're
fast I'm gonna be in Austin Texas
oh [ __ ] congratulations thanks a week
from week from tomorrow the eighteenth
nineteen Twenty twenty four no nineteen
twenty twenty first twenty second austex
a cap city comedy club nice go to Ari's
a [ __ ] calm yeah
and just newly announced oh [ __ ] drop it
everybody buckle your seatbelts here it
comes the New York Comedy Festival may
be Danish dinner Neil or doing a live
read of the script I wrote in college
called shooter oh yeah oh that should be
really good I'm really excited for you
not a great first oh I bet it isn't are
you guys gonna do any punching up or
just act it no no just are you gonna
just let him do cold reason gonna let
him get it ahead of time and let him get
some ready I'll let them all up read it
again see what they can do it lit up let
them get their teeth into the script as
they say yeah the words but not tour but
what you can do is you know bring it to
life
now are they each gonna play how many
characters are in yeah yeah tell us the
main characters huh I know they goodness
are they gonna be playing multiple
characters and we'll know which
character by their awesome accents and
dialects
ladies and gentleman during episode 300
the fight mommy welcome do we've been
waiting for you
for 15 minutes we've been sitting here
waiting for fit and finally we said [ __ ]
it we'll do it live for 3 minutes all
right Johnny and I have been waiting for
15 minutes Sam's been waiting for 3 well
that's our he's actually been waiting
for a dog time that's how I was fought
the first that's 40 minutes yeah he's
our new yeah well that's a good guess
for the big get is already fear for our
300 so he's telling us at the New York
Comedy Festival me are gonna be doing a
live reading you know about this so now
are they gonna each be playing a
character how many care
are you guys just doing a just a read uh
well we got shooter obviously the main
character we got his nemesis mmm I
forgot his name probably for the best
oh yeah sure you got nemesis roommate
then you got plot twist I notice a lot
of people in of names antagonist
we got coach we got in tagging Astakhov
hero pretty girl we high verse be
sensitive we have pretty girl we have
ethnic we're a snick role now since it's
about a college basketball team is this
immense or women's team because I know
when you're in college you don't know a
lot of men's basketball but you are
quite prolific in the world of getting
posted up by at hua University Maryland
fastest player for the girls team under
coach Hall of Fame coach Chris Keller
how much did I guarantee you at that
point in time in your life that [ __ ]
ate a lot more [ __ ] than you have and
one of them was your mom on the way out
you just like no nobody I'm Ella
I'm very with you okay hey Ari where
else you gonna be is that it your
[ __ ] dates are the gates you're like
all black comic introducing the next
comic said this guy he's like a date say
and probably in 2020 I'll have some
other dates me uh once again I'll plug
it again all of us will be at the all
things comedy festival at the end of
October so that's gonna be super fun if
you are he's doing a theater show with
Bill Byrne all the big guys I'm gonna be
doing a stand-up set right outside the
dumpster but all of us gonna be doing
stand-up we're gonna do a live punch um
that'll be super fun I'm also a yum yum
gimme some that's not a comedy club
that's a Chinese place I do and I'll
also be getting a I sell doughnut still
I don't think so I think it's pretty
much just like noodles and crack and I'm
also going to be
getting a DUI in one of those lime
[ __ ] scooters probably around 2:00
a.m. I hate those things I wonder if you
could you probably could could of course
like swerve around like I'd be like hey
I hate you I'm John Deere lawn mowers I
see that happen I hate those things do
you give a [ __ ] about him no the birds
so yeah those little like every time I
see something I'm like yeah they ban
them in West Hollywood
they bandana for no other purpose of
just being [ __ ] yeah they're all
over your neighborhood really hard
they're all over your neighborhood we
don't jef li gets so angry and there's
no one who's more politically activated
than a mother they just love to start an
initiative and show up at [ __ ] my
County meetings if you don't know we're
talking about this all these electric
scooters that are all over Los Angeles
it's about five major cities by the way
if you would have invested in that
company right now early you were getting
rich as [ __ ] I know - and well Benjy
showed up with a injured hand his hands
like all kind of bandages because he was
in Austin and [ __ ] himself up in one
of those and then yeah uh-huh
and then Brady Matthew's girlfriend
comes in on crutches I'm like oh what
happened your leg and their ankles all
wrapped up and she's like oh I [ __ ]
got an accident one of those scooters
how is that gonna sue them I mean that
that's just you can't operate this thing
you understand me this thing's going out
there six months and I already know of
like three people that have been like
injured from them and those are smart
people imagine how many dumb Fox
thin the herd thin the hurt it's
Darwinism Darwinism guys this weekend is
the big tin foil hat comedy night comedy
weekend at the corner comedy club in
Niagara Falls Canada Friday and Saturday
Eddie Bravo myself should be fun we've
sold a bunch tickets already would like
to sell more so come out and rock I will
have a local comic opening then we would
to be doing stand-up and then
answering all your questions about
bisexual lizard pay Paul and then what's
a question yeah you do have a lot of an
October 3rd I will be at the Brea improv
I have George Perez the Smash Brothers
Corrine Chad Mike Catherwood from k-rock
and then Mike Tully so come out grab
your tickets now at Brea improv calm
that's it yay yay get in get out get a
Gaga a gig a gigai guys this is episode
300 I think we go through some of our
favorite memories throughout the two I
recently saw the [ __ ] and I recently
saw the fat man he's there like yeah
he'll go to all the same shows and he's
there like every Monday he goes like
once or twice a week but who doesn't
remember our oft forgotten and never
launched buddy cop movie the fat man and
the [ __ ] it even had their own theme
song remember he always would play the
theme song for it yeah
ah memories god I miss Renee we got
stuck with Johnny who's texting because
you know I'm texting a link to the show
you dick you dick he's doing that was
that was a great moment the dildo corn
episodes probably is the highlight of
this show even though it isn't part of
this 300 but it is my favorite when are
you into dildo on your head and I'm like
fart funnel when you suck a fart out of
ours [ __ ] so that was a good why are
you on the mic right now we're talking
and then we'll get to the [ __ ]
interns okay [ __ ] off ah when you came
in and the chick talked about what she
talked about getting raped oh yeah oh
yeah I don't know where what the knife
to the throat is that's another chick
that's Renee's port and start Hall of
Fame oh yeah forgot was that who was
doing porn back when it's a game you
wanna meet my cousin she used to be
point so we're like absolutely yeah
definitely and then you know my question
is how many times he watches cuz he get
boned right of course of course that's
your quest yeah well there
would be your question I said that's a
con show Johnny you welcome back fart
funnel is not that great didn't get any
views nobody panic nobody cared nobody
cares the best thing I'm not taping like
the the gift that kept on giving like
yeah you're gonna get it because you
have to suck a fart out his ass but me
just strap and duct tape on are his
hairy ass but he doesn't even think
about having literally got his hairy ass
waxed yeah yeah last night last night at
a at a kill Tony they had one of the
jackass guys on which I can't recall but
yeah yeah yeah and at the end of it
Jamie Watkins got his pubes and [ __ ]
waxed I gotta be honest man I've been
watching Jeremiah lately he's been doing
really well oh yeah of course he I've
been very impressed with his SATs lately
man and I'm just like that's Comedy
Store that's like when you get that
Comedy Store magic yeah and it's hard to
get now because there's so many people
there's not as many fine opportunities
you got to do characters and other
people's show I did this funky jump and
Johnson just shot this really funny like
pilot and she's like hey I want you to
do a thing and like I was literally
there on the fly was just creating a
character that's good I mean and then at
the end of it she's like hey [ __ ] you
gotta be doing that [ __ ] more like when
I want to make that a permanent
character Mike you have to do that dog
yeah when you get called the n-word by
black person by poop uncle says that to
everybody yeah but but you have to do
that like that's what Jeremiah did and
kill Tony he's like okay I don't get a
lot of spots here I'm gonna create a
spot ya gotta do that if you want to
bang in the story you have to create
your own opportunities
yeah when you get those little ones you
got to do what you can to make them
bigger yes sure breaking news Ari
Shaffir [ __ ] Jeremiah whoa that is
breaking news
that is that is breaking news so I was
watching um Jeremiah and Regan it says
name right yeah Pat Regan Pat Regan that
is going to be one of the most funny
dynamics to watch because one guys
literally like a devout Christian and
the other one is just a madman and you
watch them on stage and their energies
are so totally different I mean it
totally kills like they're like dude
they got something really good and you
can go really far but just watching the
dynamics of them is going to be the bet
the best part of watching that show
because it will eventually blow up no
Regan and Watts yeah it's really funny
like an album coming out dude they're
really good and so so lesson so I'm
doing the Icehouse
it's called tenacious d cub yeah is it
no but it's funny dude and uh so I get
help by chairman hey dude can I go up
before you because I gotta get for the
improper I'm like sure Jarrell you can
go up and then all of a sudden I see
it's the whole show and I'm like [ __ ]
why'd I let [ __ ] Cirque du Soleil go
on rape before me they're gonna expect
that now the audience oh yeah this old
man Sam walking up there there's just
like two three twenty thirty year old
guys dude and says jokes about butt
sacks and girls are like Oh fell funny
and I go I'm talking about butt sex
people are calling cops cuz I'm a
registered sex offender but uh it was
funny the [ __ ] watch dude I thought
they were great and that's my commentary
so those are my comics to watch for this
week everybody
new segment everybody the best guests
we've had here in 300 episodes what do
you guys think
Oh sports bands very popular
I'm Mickey galls probably pretty popular
I mean when you factor in I don't want
to say punch-drunk made Mickey gone yeah
but Dolph's that I was just thinking
that actually that he was nothing
without us he was a fan of our show
before he saw him he was a fan of our
show before he signed with the UFC yeah
calling in to us when he was on that
making a fighter yeah shell yeah well
because I called I called Dana and said
you got to take this guy yeah and Dana
was
he didn't want to at first and I was
like please mr. Dana White please yeah I
told Rogan I go Rogan you got to see
this guy fight and he goes who are you
and I'll never forget that I'll never
forget that what did you guys think
about the the Elon Musk's [ __ ] we talked
about it at the party on Saturday I feel
so bad for that guy why please maybe
guys think I can't do anything again
have any fun you know I'm a billionaire
that's got being a billionaire a billion
[ __ ] dollars yeah so Johnny or Elon
Johnny I think this is just autistic
feeling for autistic is that what this
is might be I think do you think it was
shouldn't have smoked pot I think he's
personally trying to tank the prices so
he could buy it okay
that's never really a conspirator
podcast yesterday oh sure brats I did it
Marcus yes but there was a guy on there
that was like a financial like God like
he that's what he did he worked for like
Nasdaq for [ __ ] eight years and yeah
he's he's not in trouble for smoking pot
and for drinking one shot of whiskey in
an hour which both things are legal in
this place and by the way he's smoked
weed like an eighth grader like there's
a part of him like yeah he's like like
an eighth grader that was hanging out
high school kids and he's like I smoke
dope to Amelia you know that voice
that'll be better do it and then give it
back to Rogen gave me back to Brooke
another broken smoke the entire thing
yeah and then so it I don't know what he
did that's wrong but the guy that was on
this show with me was like exactly what
you're saying which isn't even really
conspiracy he was talking about going
private but yeah I'm gonna buy all this
yeah and now that that's why the SC's is
looking at him yeah and then smokes weed
and does it drip out of whiskey in an
hour and then
like the the guy that quit was the H&R
guy quit yeah which is like I don't want
nothing to do with this like this is my
you know I mean it's like some kid puked
in the [ __ ] hallway at high school
and the janitors like I'm out somebody
else clean that up yeah that's what that
front page of CNN the next letter was
like does Ilan need help counties hold
on horn as a Jew talk about stop yes
okay true okay no problem dude
that isn't quite dude part of this yeah
Jew or false on the rest of his new car
way behind he's asked for two extensions
and people like what's going on as he
but he's complained he's cried in
interviews before saying the pressure is
getting to me
this is a guy who kind of like MIT see
where he is the company yeah he's not
just like the CEO he is the company good
example so he's behind on stuff he's
crying and now he's like you know what
[ __ ] it I'm gonna try smoking weed and
people at this point are going hey we
better jump off this ship yeah no way
this guy's going it's fine if he wants
no part that's not who I want leading my
[ __ ] multi-billion dollar corporation
he's just he's flailing down into this
path of self-discovery and that's great
even wants to [ __ ] go to Thailand for
five months but I can be great for my
stocks Steve Jobs ran Apple without a
liver for like three years
why he smokes a joint and we're good
thing is that Apple produced you know
this guy is according to the Jew weekly
over here okay isn't delivering on what
he's what he's supposed to deliver on
that's when people start getting nervous
and then there's a chance that this star
force is a direct like a [ __ ] this guy
you know yeah spaceforce
Rick Ingraham stop smoking weed because
he wasn't doing well on his life Elon
Musk is not doing well and now he's
starting to smoke I don't think he
smoked pot I mean it didn't look like a
smoke pot have you watched it he's just
like no I did he look like
did that he's like he's like Bill
Clinton he didn't inhale
and he got blown by a fat chick and then
he's dating [ __ ] Amber Heard is he
still dating that [ __ ] soul sucker
know who is yeah who amber her he was
like ray after she just scorched the
earth with Johnny death and just
completely ruined him like that vagina
is vu do whatever any any man that
enters that [ __ ] cave of death okay
your [ __ ] will go to even worse it will
go wherever bad you are it's even worse
it's so weird that Amber Heard went from
Johnny multi-millionaire Johnny Depp to
inventor Elon Musk
she's a renaissance woman she like so
many different things cash homes or the
type [ __ ] like like I like Jewish girls
with big tits you like black strippers
that have cocaine in their butthole like
Johnny likes guys yeah for sure are true
for sure Ari likes women that could take
a punch we all have a time you gotta get
what you're into Aaron likes women that
aren't his wife we did it everybody has
a thing here we go check it out over
there he what is he like Angela yeah
it's a blunt it's a sick man I thought
of it as the artistic guy tell us what
he's thinking right now just tasted it
like a [ __ ] cigar you know yeah of
course he is dude he came up with PayPal
which was an amazing idea and it just
blew off self landing-rockets
Peter tiyanak that dude self
landing-rockets that's true
listen if you're using us for goods or
services you gotta give me three percent
but if you just said it to a friend and
that's free yeah please honest I think
you found in the other actually it was
people Ari I need your dress again for
some cash I forgot to Santa I need your
address can you email it thank you no
I'm not PayPal and unless you want taxes
yeah
just say it on air right now all right
just email me it unless like I can send
it to you on PayPal it's gonna take a
giant chunk if you're fine with that
any other business I don't know I can't
hear it just text it to me dude it's one
five one first step okay dude I'm just
gonna be cool because I asked him to
he's a man I can't hear you I can't hear
you
what's your kids gate code can you
really not hear me
I can't well how did you respond I am
working I don't have time do you're the
one that brought it up what are you
talking about Johnny you've used up all
your talking tokens ari what's your gate
code at the door though if you want to
get in if you don't have a key lets you
into steal packages okay cool yeah
what's the door guy's name so you just
say hey what's up Ramon oh man what a
wonderful time to be alive guys there's
a lot of great [ __ ] going on and you
could see it all live thanks to our good
friends at secret yes uh CC gig seat
geek for all of your ticketing needs
whatever you're going to see man
whatever you're going to see say
concerts I just saw Alice in Chains long
I've asked you a question
yeah a ticket one place what's up how
many tickets are in one place a lot of
them there's a lot of tickets the answer
that a million in one put millions of
tickets there's that many tickets in the
world and they're all available at Sikhi
concerts my sister just got tickets on
seeking she went to the forum sister see
she went to go see the Game of Thrones
Orchestra oh that's got to be great you
don't say that that's also music use ik
I saw it just saw Elson chains they
totally Rock the first four songs I'm
like were you guys going with this were
you guys going with this was a new
suffers it was like some of their it was
their old stuff but wasn't any of the
class like the ones that they're known
for the first four I'm like oh dude this
might be a little rough and then at the
end they were just throttling dude it
was like some bucket list [ __ ] here like
wood and then a rooster BAM but man it
was but you know what the tickets were
cheap thanks to seeking go to see geeky
download the app alright go download the
app put in the promo code punch-drunk
and get what jason 20 ramps look good
you get 20 bucks off your first purchase
hey man let's say you find let's say
your MLB team is out of the playoffs
like a lot of them except for but if
they are mine's not yet well our take
but our tickets would be pretty
expensive you can get 20 bucks off but
let's say you're a fan of some shitty
team like the Pittsburgh Pirates or I
don't know the Seattle Mariners guess
what $5 tickets get two of those free
whoa really free Wow see geek really has
it going so it's very simple and all the
tickets all their tickets are guaranteed
you're not gonna get ripped off by some
scumbag earns shyster or some Russian
trying to fix the system their tickets
are guaranteed so true to buy them you
have nothing to worry about so true NFL
is in full swing
yeah go grab those tickets right now you
want to see the rams rock you want to
see the Raiders Rock you want to see one
of those things happen tonight you can
see Marlins and Mets for dollars that's
exactly I'm saying that means Sikhi yet
I called it I called the shot I called
the shot no you could go if it's a
doubleheader go to both games and it's
still free I don't know go to that buzz
now will you sixteen dollars that was
just a joke did you know you 60 now so
go ahead and cut that out Johnny could
you timestamp that cut that on that seat
double intercom or some key cap and get
the app don't even go to the website
yeah what do you do carry your laptop
around like a like Elon Musk get yeah
what are you gonna not smoke weed come
on man get they get the app see geek
loves you and we love C key Sam asked
Elon Musk what he thinks about C geek uh
uh Elon Musk real quick what do you
think about seeking
as a fantastic question oh yeah as I
pontificate about now I don't even
really I imagine that's a fantastic
service but I don't I don't need 23
dollars I perhaps after smoking this I
might I might need 23 dollars thank you
Sam and that's Elon Musk loving seedcake
even though he doesn't need $20 Thank
You sneaky alright - lets get into it
last night Raiders look good for 1/4 1/2
1/2 we were Super Bowl champions hmm oh
that's a big that's a big bleep for well
we're beating the best team in the
league
the Rams aren't the best team RAM is
probably best team in Lake goes are the
best team but the Rams do what they do
I mean that's exactly the Rams are like
a box look like a Lennox Lewis a boxer
with a great jab you might get a good
shot in on him in the first second third
round but you're just taking that
[ __ ] jab like if you look they're
built for playoff football yeah they're
built for the 4th quarter that defense
is great and [ __ ] girly just wears
you down wears you down
where's you know I mean Golf through 10
passes in the first half 10 passes in
the first half he don't have to throw
they'll take these shots but all of
girlies 4 yard runs in the first half
are 16 yard runs in the second half
because now that jab is just now your
[ __ ] face is swollen from that jab
that's what they're gonna do all year
long they lose girly they're a different
team but man that
they just wear you down if you know you
beat the Rams you're up somehow 24 to 3
at halftime and you're gonna win you
know 31 took [ __ ] 20 yeah you got to
get up so big that they can't come back
because they're gonna wear you down that
second half was Ted's all-star team ten
seven a half-time
it was 13 10 13 10 okay a three-point
game when it was 13 10 a halftime I'm
like where are the teams down they end
up winning the second half that time Sam
when it was thought it was a 3-point
game a hard time I'm like the Rams are
going to
win by two types re thank you for taking
what Tebow just said and just making it
more Joey thank you for that that you
literally just said what he just said
yeah okay do you still think the Raiders
make the playoffs I did we weren't
expected to win the fact that we had a
decent first half I'll take it
Marshawn Lynch maybe my favorite player
in the NFL
Marshawn Lynch might be might that
touchdown he scored was awesome yeah
where was it no it was in the shittiest
stadium in the world this [ __ ] we played
in the shittiest stadium in baseball
yeah in baseball
it's the worst Stadium there's like two
different times like Cooper Cup who's
sure-handed
was like running backwards and trying to
catch a pass and then it's like now he's
into the [ __ ] dirt and he's on like
30 second base and just [ __ ] just
slips in the dirt so yeah I dropped it
sometimes of dollars and they can't walk
amazing at me oh I have a good bag of
bets I'd like to know you guys is good
this is good though loser has to get a
Mark Davis haircut thank you Thank You
Aaron pull it up this guy is a
billionaire he his father is a was a
billion died if he inherited the Raiders
has more so much money it's [ __ ]
he's doesn't assess the haircut you get
when nobody can tell you anything yep
BAM it's like dumb it's like it looks
like Eric Marino's audition tape for
Dumb and Dumber yeah look at that dude I
mean whoever cuts out here I should be
like should I say so I heard last night
I can't recall who said this but I heard
last night that he flies he flies you
Florida to get his hair cut by one
person in one person only
no dude the only person who would do
that [ __ ] on you you are telling me that
makes no sense
the moon is hollow is telling me that
makes no sense yeah yeah it doesn't make
any sense he has a personal barber that
he only goes to to Florida to do that no
because the rumor before that was a
drove a hundred miles to get this
haircut every week beat-up old car let's
see who told me that Oh Mark Davis told
me that
yeah I mean I makes no sense to me
either
but that's something a guy like that
would do any you know he still drives
the same Caravan yeah and he drives it
too like supposedly a hundred miles away
once a week to get his [ __ ] hair done
but I'm saying you're that rich and you
the guy look at that that's great is he
married I don't know who would marry
that I know but people like money yeah I
think that's money going hey give me a
shot the title right there would you let
him [ __ ] you for a million dollars you
let people help you milk show what what
a shocker
how does she let him get that haircut
that's insane you know why she hates him
and doesn't give a [ __ ] and she's just
waiting for Jenna it's true cuz we like
care about how you dress and stuff I bet
I bet she's like hey let's do every time
they fought she goes you know what
really turns me on when I wear a
blindfold
ya know she's probably it's like when
you date a girl and she starts feeding
you so you get fat and you become
unfuckable what that's his wife he's
dressed like Miami Vice in their photo
look at the [ __ ] way you don't get to
that level and they're not paying that
type of strength Crockett in scrubs
right there damn I would love to be
their pool boy because you know he's
[ __ ] spraying her down the language
the language yeah so I'm pretty
optimistic I'm really exciting this with
a more queer criminal what's that oh
look at that
yeah I hate that [ __ ] dude that's
Sam's team and Sam's best buddy oh yeah
two best friends right they're hanging
out making plans knocking down buildings
um we are so I guess Oakland is suing
the Raiders right now and so next year's
like where they play is up for grabs
they because they say diem is not to be
done did you see the footage of your
stadium in a hole right now yeah there's
nothing there that would seem there's
zero chance that's gonna be ready next
year and they have no lease with Oakland
next year because they're supposed to be
Oakland two years and then Vegas there's
a zero chance that stadium is going to
be done
they'll just move into San Francisco to
teams mm-hmm so that's where they'll
probably end up playing that's probably
probably that's probably that's the most
logical thing yeah and then they'll move
to I mean god I wish they'd just move
the [ __ ] Chargers to Vegas the
Chargers have no chance literally don't
buy 20 years didn't sell out Game one
that's what does a live view right there
okay that's your stadium right there
it's a hole with looking good dude right
across from it it's right on the 15 it's
right across the street I love utilize
it you make it happen it's right across
here you can see the Mandalay Bay I mean
it'll be nice I'm just saying it's not
gonna be that is not gonna be done 300
days do you know what a bag of bats that
no I wouldn't either they can get a lot
more done in the fall and winter than
they can in the summer oh thank you hey
Ron Thank You Man and the truth is that
this is Vegas and they build [ __ ] fast
we've been building [ __ ] casinos
forever so when we put our mind to it we
can do it Vegas strong it won't be done
it's fine I know but you're gonna yeah
well I mean it'll be done more concerned
about LA what charge LA I don't think
we'll be done next you think it's a good
idea to be in this I mean like it is a
horrible idea see you can look at the
Clippers and go look how long's take
them to get any comedy thousand seats
they couldn't sell out Game one yeah
they're [ __ ] man it's the worst
business idea I've ever know the thing
you know they just jump up to this and
they're a good team yeah they're a good
team they don't have a fan base they're
a good team leaving San Diego was the
dumbest thing I ever did it was so dumb
well San Diego San Diego did that it's
not the chart I mean they were forced
out they would beg to differ
oh the ownership held the city ransom
and and they bolted well they voted no
they voted I'm not building a new
stadium they voted I'm not building a
new stadium wanted billions of dollars
yeah that's why they should be in bad
terrible ownership the Vegas Chargers
it should be the Vegas chargers we mean
Vegas gets two teams says no and then we
should be in LA oh the Los Angeles
charges of Anaheim I have a crazy
prediction Sam's crazy predictions I
know I I believe that the Buffalo Bills
are tanking it so that they can move to
Toronto right now that's my honest
opinion watching what they're doing
right now and how much dead cap space
they have when I've watched this happen
before with the st. Louis Rams when they
filled a [ __ ] team and then I saw
Seattle do it with the SuperSonics when
they purposely [ __ ] super tanked it
so nobody went to the games and how
buffalo is operating right now is so
dumb that it has to be almost purposeful
that is my opinion because that area is
shrinking in terms of population which
means it's a smaller pool to pull from
and Toronto is a one such a good fan
base though I'm telling you dude look
how much the Seattle SuperSonics how
much they love that [ __ ] team and
left Cleveland man Cleveland had a great
great fan base I think I think they are
[ __ ] tanking it too and the team just
got solving the new orders like no we're
gonna keep the team here yeah y'all yeah
yeah I'm not in new leadership to you
know new coaches GM I think the but I
think then it's close enough to Buffalo
that some people be like [ __ ] okay I'll
go
I think doc there's this new model that
like the Rams are doing that Eagles are
doing the Browns are doing where it's
like you have when you have a rookie
quarterback when you have a guide that's
gonna make 30 million dollars a year in
five years on a four-year four seven
million dollar contract so you have all
this cap space because one of your
marquee players you're he's gonna break
the bank in four years that's where you
get your four year window that's how the
Rams defense is stacked as [ __ ] because
they don't in four years when asked to
pony up for golf and [ __ ] wins and
all those guys when you have to pony up
in four years oh they're the Rams
defense gonna employ
they might lose Gurley that you know to
mean though black can't pay everybody
you can't pay everybody so all these
teams that are good have these rookie
quarterbacks playing for low money
superstars playing for low money and
then they can afford to pay all these
crazy people the only I think that's
what the bills are due the only other
model is well yeah now that they got
their booking quarterback next two years
they're just gonna throw crazy money at
you so much dead money gosh I look bad
man so much but he came yeah their
offensive line sucks but he came into
the game down g'wan a David Carr your
quarterback I think dude and it starts
why would that not kill their future
like a sitting [ __ ] tie rod or tie rod
or whatever is Rob Rogers let you know
against the Rams - rod when they were a
playoff team and they're like now we're
gonna sit him and then it they still
made the playoffs but was like what are
you doing why are you taking this it's
like so hard to make the [ __ ]
playoffs and you [ __ ] purposely
[ __ ] sit this guy and it's just like
I just got the same sense I get when I
when I was watching the NFL and say when
I was watching the Rams in st. Louis
when they purposely didn't feel the team
and then Seattle was the same thing they
purposely tanked it and that's might be
all that dead money you [ __ ] sign
somebody how many people did they sign
and then let go or trade I just makes no
sense
everybody's team lost on the show except
for mine Johnny's and Johnny beat you re
Dallas look bad I personally Elliot
what's what's going on I'm gonna make a
producer now boys are leaving Dallas
there's no but cowboys and carrots and a
Vegas Cowboys - Vegas makes a lot of
sense the Cowboys are easy to scheme
against yeah carousel it win the game
what does he have on Jerry Jones that he
keeps getting to come back every year
he's got some picture a [ __ ] of
basically a Russian hooker peeing on him
yeah yeah for sure let him in Trump guys
they got another
diction the running back for the Giants
will be the next Barry Sanders there you
go put it out there he's good he looked
I mean he didn't just look good dude you
see that guy but I need to take it away
now and everybody he looks great
Oh anybody mean if you take away that
one six yard touchdown he had a okay
game that one touchdown put him over the
top but the same thing with Gurley last
night yeah but this kid moves
differently everybody else everybody
it's like when I talk about like Steph
Curry or Kyrie Irving versus like
everybody else he's a throwback so
easily like that it's fluid it's like
Russell s per pound the ball mu it's
everything's rough until like every
other running back it's like hard yards
hard yards he's got this can't boom he
just like just moves at a different
speed than everyday bills the bills by
the way they have seven million dollars
in cash base fifty three million dollars
in Dead Money that's what I'm saying it
makes no sense man that's like literally
like dude that's creepy [ __ ] that you're
doing right there I knew would make
sense you taint this 53 out of 127
million dollars right dude he's half
they're almost half their cash that's
not even smart it's just a bad GM unless
that's what you're trying to do but
those are my two big predictions I
really like I like them thank you
Cowboys maybe who's the worst team the
worst team I mean it's hard to say after
week one I mean the bills are pretty bad
bill the liens look pretty bad loss I
feel so bad for the lion Bartels but I
feel hard oh that bad you dude I mean
like this when the other team say they
know your signals and you're a brand new
coach and they know your signals some of
the Lions yeah they look bad and he's a
defensive coach I am a defense look like
garbage yeah I mean did you just tell
there are some there are some hirings
they got be like oh man the Browns it
was a crazy day it was a crazy day at a
red zone one of the longest days we've
had because this Steelers game goes to
overtime and then is a tie the poor
Browns looks like they're gonna beat
their rival and
finally gonna win and you know when they
get a win everybody at the stadium gets
free beer they have the they have these
big beer things that are locked up in
Chains and whenever they finally get a
win they're gonna unchain them and then
everybody gets free beer so I would
imagine
everybody's got be stale by juic they
had this bottom line this lower third
that said zero zero and one Brown's best
start since 2004 that's amazing how bad
are you always hard to see them that's
hilarious they play to a tie so that
game goes forever the longest game in
the history of the NFL happened Sunday
which was the Titans and Miami yeah
Miami they play the first quarter it's a
morning game they play the first quarter
two hour delay because of lightning yeah
oh I see you're saying the late game
start this game hasn't even come back on
yet they then they restart the first
quarter they get to the second quarter
another hour delay that game was still
on when all of the afternoon games ended
so it started at 10 o'clock did you get
stick around I mean that was the last
game so we didn't have stick around for
that but it made us go late because of
that game wasn't so gone we would have
bounced but we had to wait for every
game to end and that was still going so
whenever there's one game left that's
when we wrapped but a little fantasy
football review uh Sam you won you'd be
Steve Rannazzisi I got heroine I got
hammered
I'm 911 that feels pretty good you lost
to Ola Tosun and plus you see 99 260 did
who lost Jason did I won I beat Josh
Martin 129 to 71 that's do you look Chad
Zuma Cleveland Cleveland [ __ ] one 113
a 103 that is unbelievable I do drafted
like a number can we get Chad to call in
cuz we were just pounding on our we're
about a minute away from a very special
okay 300 episode call but I then we
should get zoo man calling he literally
had one of the worst rafts you would
ever ever know he never played fantasy
football we had a good night calling in
300 let's take a call for episode 300
welcome to punch-drunk hello hello who
do we have on the were calling bill
Barolo me the Godfather of all things
comedy
thank you brother the original podcast
yeah yeah I appreciate that thank you
Bill thanks for calling them we
appreciate well I'll be sure to continue
walking around so I just go in and out
the entire time perfect specialness of
this episode perfect for punch honk yeah
that's exactly how we roll oh yeah oh
yeah it's been one of them as a host
actually yeah yeah what one of them's in
New York right now
Ari Shaffir all right bill did you watch
a lot of the NFL this week yes I did
well I watched the Patriots game I saw
some of the highlights off obviously saw
Aaron Rodgers and I watched some of the
rams Raiders last night dude what a
[ __ ] baller is is goddamn Aaron
Rodgers I know my buddy text me said oh
no man Aaron Rodgers grabbed his knee it
looks like a season ender ender and all
that and I thought that guy's just yeah
he's a peach he's just like he's the the
Tom Brady of the NFC that is what he is
that's exactly what he is that's exactly
I think that's it that's exactly right
he's the Tom Brady of the NFC it's like
those are the two you don't want to [ __ ]
with in week ones and not just sit out
the rest of the game they're down 20
nothing he goes a onic heart comes back
and you're like is that [ __ ] guy back
and now he's limping around just
throwing [ __ ] frozen ropes can you
imagine the Bears fans I mean good lord
and you know it's funny it's like how
they just in my entire life have never
been able to draft it the right guy at
the quarterback position and to watch
the Packers go from Brett Favre to Aaron
Rodgers no she's very rare that you know
like look at the dog
like once damn marina left this still
waiting for their next guy to go yeah
you know you got to do what the cults do
is when your guy gets old what you do
and then do is don't let them play and
then you tank the whole thing yeah so
you're in a position to draft and then
nobody calls you out on cheating right
then what you do is you hire a guide and
get Brady suspended for an under
inflated ball and bears can't seem to
get that they just can't seem to get the
memo on that did you watch any the Jets
game at all I mean Donaldson or Donald's
looks [ __ ] great and then Cleveland
goes with Mayfield who must still might
be uh pretty good but Don looks like the
real deal there I mean like you throw a
pick six on your batter ever and then
yet he'd be like he had to [ __ ] his
pants when he did that he's like uh-oh
and then dude that just come back and
put 40 on like the Detroit Lions where
their coach is like a defensive
specialist it's like unbelievable yeah I
mean you could have ESP I can't go ESPN
here and watch the guy play one game the
next 15 right it's it's a promising
start I remember you know Sanchez after
three games my buddy calling me up
saying hey that guy's a star he's out
there seein things and all the Jets have
a history of getting fans have a history
of getting really excited so now I gotta
be honest with you like I'm just trying
to enjoy the last I don't know how many
seasons we're gonna have with Brady and
Belichick and uh I just can't you know
we're obviously I mean 90% through
through through the tank at this point
so it's got to be one or two more
seasons that how many you think one or
two maybe I mean after this maybe next
year and the year after maybe at the
most I mean he's 41 now yeah he doesn't
get hit you know his wife made some sort
of comment about him you know getting
concussions and I think he did all those
quarterback sneaks maybe or you know and
forth and one that he's done he's
probably done a thousand of those so
good may be that he is he is but he got
hit really hard
this pass game and that's when I finally
Donna because like I don't remember Tom
taking too many big hits but then I just
watch them sneak in the balm like baby
that's where it is but uh Pat's had a
hell of a run
I don't know how many more we can have
out of it so bad if I was a Jets fan I
would be excited because know hopefully
obviously we're gonna go back to be in
the Patriots they were they were the
worst team yeah they were then we just
had like all these embarrassing you know
the Olsen woman look poor reporter was
in the the locker room and again they
said all this crap to her we just had a
lot of that that's just Boston know sort
of ineptness we just that but hey that's
just Boston did you just say that [ __ ]
really everywhere that's that shooter
would you say Boston is the one busting
scandal and we get lumped in with
everybody down south how they act like
all the racism and all the idiocy of the
world is either in Boston or down south
become a comedian go on the road right
everywhere hey would you say Boston is
the only city that it's Mount Rushmore
of sports is 3/4 white I mean you got
Tom Brady right bird bird Bobby Orr
right and then it would be what Bill
Russell is the lab would be the fourth
one American city anyway like the kid in
Canada they're always Williams for sure
Carl Yastrzemski Larry Bird yeah wake
Allah my god Bobby Orr
Pedro Martinez Pedro Martinez great one
Big Papi yeah Jesus Christ I mean we
there's too many - yeah too many to name
so interest so do you watch any tennis
at all I used to watch recent times I
think you I thought that hosts the Riu
thing was hilarious
I do people a lot of people exciting
it's racism and then you look at the
chick she's playing and she's also black
yeah well that is true well no I think
also when they actually what they were
saying was happening was happening they
got busted he was giving her signals but
I think they all do it like she's taking
steroids it was just like the guy was
you know giving a couple little pointers
he got busted and I just thought I want
to learn yeah yeah then it just becomes
that I'm fighting for all women's rights
you're playing tennis yeah well you know
she was funny
the sisters thought kind of funny I
don't think it was that big of a deal
that everybody made out of it and then
but she definitely you know blew the
bugle and all these social justice
people came running to then talk and and
then to examine this poor umpire who's
literally just doing his job
he busted you getting signals from your
coach you know yeah I respect that she
denied it and it was funny that she
brought her kid into it but at the end
of the day everybody people are still
just you know this that was the guy
doing it what could have happened you
know that Ruth oh it's like she's
playing a woman she's cheating against a
woman so and it's just so yeah 38 years
old right and the played this when like
most the most female athletes in
particularly tennis the bottom falls out
at at 30 it falls out man and so she
gets tested all the time and you know
you see people you see like Brett Favre
Nolan Ryan you know and then you put
LeBron James and there's two that that
play for so long and that you're like
okay occasionally you have these guys
that can play our tool or cologne yeah
yeah but you look at their physiques and
you're like some of these people are
shredded at 38 when everyone around them
is not except Bartolo Colon like
everybody except for him it's all fat
guys a belief they could do it but you
know she complains that she gets tested
more than anybody it's like yeah because
you're playing at the super high level
at 38 and you look completely different
than everybody else you play every do
you think that cartoons races
she's always looked at princes always
been bigger so uh you know I wouldn't I
wouldn't begrudge it at that point but I
will say yeah that for her to be playing
tennis at that level I mean usually by
the time they're 26 you're getting that
they're usually getting on a divorce you
know they usually marry their coach
right like that and you know party too
much and kind of mess the whole thing up
but I think no I think she's awesome
everything I just I thought the whole
thing's funny I love gamesmanship I love
them people you know put too much pine
tar and do all that kind of BS like I
think all of that stuff is it's funny to
me I don't know why everybody flips out
about it and they get all all surprised
that someone would try to you know have
an advantage oh here are their yeah
exactly yeah everybody everybody does it
that's what's so funny about the NFL and
being a Patriots fan is listening to all
these cheaters saying that we're
cheating it's just like well yeah we are
so are you I mean I don't know what like
like I've I've always brought up like
the Seattle Seahawks like they built
that state and it makes their fans sound
louder than they really are that's such
[ __ ] like I've gone to a game and
just the pregame chatter was like
annoyingly loud and people were just
sitting there talking
I think they we'd lose draft picks they
do that Legion of boom like I swear to
God like for like three or four those
guys all tested positive for roids yeah
and it was just like it's just all swept
under the rug but it's like everybody's
doing it and I always find the and that
steroid they don't find steroids funny
but I find all of that stuff you know
just funny yeah are trying to get away
with stuff when the ref isn't looking
all of its hilarious and people like
they take it it like like it's like you
disrespected the flag or something and
then meanwhile you have a corporation
that took over the food supply and turn
it into poison and no one seems to give
a [ __ ] you know if you go up there but
if you go there with the cork bat all of
a sudden you gotta get in front of the
[ __ ] Senate it's stupid not ever yeah
well in baseball the history of cheating
in baseball I mean they've been cheating
in baseball as long as there's been
baseball
they were all taking amphetamines
forever to the point like people going
to Spencer fighting [ __ ] fans dude
they were all on speed bagging that
Chicago black youth a hard to do you
listen Jimmy oh go just play softball in
your 20s how banged up you feel the next
day these people in their 20s and 30s
got to play 162 games like they should
be on something before instead of means
they used to take like coffee beans or
something to get some sort of adrenaline
and it's not the G it's just a like you
know function you play 162 games there
was one guy who used to take monkey
adrenaline in like the 1890 I can't
remember his name but he would inject
monkey adrenaline before games they
didn't bust him for it they were just
like it's hard to test for it's hard to
test for hold a bunch of bananas in
front of them that's how you tested
it'll be almost like how they did with
weed where you can almost have like a
steroid like vaporizer right they get
rid of all the bad stuff and all it is
is the stuff that helps the body to
rebuild like like that dude in the fly
you know then it'll be fine but I mean
if singer can't sing they give her a
steroid there's a lot of times that you
go to the doctor's office if you're
having a problem they give you a steroid
so they're obviously good on some level
obviously the ones they took years and
years ago we're terrible but now it's
like a cream and stuff like I think
eventually they built it'll become it'll
be legal at a state level first and then
a federal level yeah yeah really is it
gives you cancer so the other people
feel like they have to do something
dangerous to keep up but if you take
away that [ __ ] then it's like no no no
it doesn't give you cancer what it does
though is if you have cancer it makes it
it basically grew up makes everything
grow so if you have cancer it makes the
tumor grow it doesn't give you cancer it
makes what if you were gonna have it go
the big problem with steroids is that
when Lyle's 8'o got it he you know look
he died from steroids there's this rumor
and again this is like a tinfoil hat
type thing that he really died of AIDS
and he didn't want anybody to know he
was gay so he told everybody with
steroids because nothing's happened like
that since so it's like
there
a good chance he was like on a DL type
stuff so that's the whole thing with
that that's just my opinion
I'll just throw that and let the
beatings begin in three well yeah dude
the bread socks
can we talk about that for a second they
are who saw that coming seems in history
everyone's talking about we knew they
were gonna be good like wind Baseball
started I didn't think they were gonna
run away with it like they have yeah but
they're not if you're if you know how to
read the tea leaves they're not
yeah that's come they've come back
people always people always freaked out
about the regular season and especially
in baseball there's 162 games and
probably a hundred of those games
October so you gotta you got to get rid
of all of that and you have to look at
how they do against Cleveland the
Yankees and the Astros and even like
Tampa Bay made it made him look like a
500 team Terry Francona is the best
manager in baseball he split and the
Astros were one run away from sweeping
us the Astros and I swear to God
and they will up on the top step like
they wanted to sweep our asses like
those are the guys everybody's talking
about the Red Sox we have all these
dining numbers but like you know I'm the
price like had a meltdown when he was in
New York and got shelled by the Yankee
so I mean that's one of those pressure
games where you have to deliver I can't
judge him on what game but like you know
I remember year all those years watching
Peyton Manning and he would throw for
like 500 yards against a bad team and so
in November and then he would lose to
the you know eight and eight charges at
home in nine and seven charges at home
two years in a row alright and it's just
like you know there's a difference
between you know regular season and big
boy time so I think if if you really
look at the Red Sox
you know I'm historically at this point
you put him up with the Seattle Mariners
who won like 120 games one year and
didn't win the World Series that's all
they've accomplished at this point and
you have to look at it that way and what
I saw with the astronauts and the Astros
are the team to beat and people are
talking about the Red Sox they're not
talking about the Astros so there
on their shoulder there you go that's my
take
that's my heart take on it what's your
take on analytics in baseball I I hate
in game analytics but I don't mind it
when it's like you're drafting or you
think about training for somebody but
within the game I think you should go
with the flow and it's really hurt the
Dodgers is here analytics has destroyed
the Dodgers nobody can get in rhythm you
know let's say we'll have a game where
we score 15 runs none of those guys will
play the next day they'll sit them all
down be like oh we're gonna go with
these guys and it's hard to get in a
flow I hate nerds in everything and in
particular baseball I think it's just
them trying to insert themselves and I
just think it's hurt the Dodgers we lost
Game seven because they went with a guy
because analytically they said it was
the best guy to go with and it he got
pounded on the first three innings that
we never came back from that do you have
any thoughts on analytics I was like
Moneyball and applying it to like
medicals issues that seems to be what it
is
yeah well that seems like it's a
brand-new science and according to you
it has not been perfected yet something
we might be onto something that will
take a few seasons to get down or
they're there what you're saying I have
no idea I mean I I just wait I'm not a
big stats guy as much as I am
what did you do during the point what
did you do at the end of the game what
is just want to count it
like those sort of like I hate to use
the word intangibles but I'm more into
that type of stuff but I do like all
times
stats and then weird stats but like that
[ __ ] when they go like you know these
guys are 2 and 7 when it's 80 degrees
out and they going back like 20 years
it's like okay nobody that you're
talking about is still playing on this
team so how is that any sort of a stat
that's that that like matters so I don't
know anyways I'm I got to go back into a
writers room here guys I appreciate
breaking oh well well well look at
[Laughter]
the planet
alright we appreciate a soar column
brother and thanks for everything and
all things comedy and we're excited for
everything you have coming down the
pipes buddy okay cool all right
congratulations on your 300 guys I'll
talk to you later thank you all right
Jeff Janis has a great bill burr
impression wasn't that fantastic
everybody before he had to go I wanted
to ask him with his make his Superbowl
predictions and his World Series
predictions but guys what's going to go
should have shown him your belt go to
bet DSi Kombat DSi for all your bet
needs and bet how long until bills back
on the show is it gonna be another 300
yeah so go go to bet DSi use a promo
code
punch 25 keep 25 dollars betting cash it
is the time to bat we got great fights
coming up my fantasy lock of the week I
mean my football lock of the week paid
off if you guys bet it it was Raiders
getting beat by the Rams and covering
and that's exactly what happened how
brave you [ __ ] I mean and a half time I
was getting text telling me how wrong I
was
I won't say who those texts were from
this pigeon over here but dude go to bed
deicide we got the triple G fight coming
up talk about gavagai us you coming on
UFC coming up the last year see wasn't
that bad that after you left the party
we got it at the party but you guys fun
yeah I thought I thought Woodley would
be - I think tail was hot so go Betty
side they're our longest-running
sponsors and we're honored to be with
them give me this week's schedule and
I'll give you the lock of the week for
what's a lot of McGregor it could be uh
we'll look that up to you look that up
on our good friends at bet DSi so good I
bet he has had I come you can bet on
anything man anything that you would
like prop bets are great everybody likes
a good prop bet
Kabhi vis minus 175 he's the favorite
okay Wow could be coming in as a
favorite McGregor at plus one and then a
man put money on that let's see if we
can change that line six it's about
three weeks from now
did you give sumac the number so we can
actually let him come in and and they'll
be great dude
so he well he drafted a kicker in like
the third round a kicker in like the
fifth ink yes three kick and three
quarterbacks yeah so bad
that's funny cuz I would have done the
same thing but well yeah he said though
he said it's my first fantasy league man
I don't know the greatest thing well
he's a Browns fan so like by week two
you're re out of the season here if you
want to call that football I mean that's
generous I think um lines Ravens at
Bengals that's a pick'em Ravens look
great I would take Ravens Ravens at
Bengals otech Ravens absolutely Panthers
at Falcons Falcons three and a half away
I wouldn't touch that Chargers at Bill's
the Chargers are favored by seven and a
half points oh yeah you're gonna
Chargers lose that might be it Vikings
at Packers the Packers the Packers are
favored by two and a half those we got
tight Texans at Titans there's no line
for that game yet sooner I'd have to see
how Marriott his health is and they lost
a Lainey Walker for way to have a lot of
injuries Browns at Saint Saints are
favored by seven and a head I wouldn't
touch that I mean the Saints their
defense let's see dolphins at jets jets
are favored by one Chiefs at Steeler
Steelers are favored by five and a half
Eagles at bucks bucks the Eagles are
favored by three Colts at Redskins
Redskins are favored by three and a half
Cardinals at Rams Rams are favored by
ten that's a lot of points Lions
49ers 49ers by three and a half Raiders
at bucks vibrators at Broncos sorry
Broncos are favored by four Pat's at
Jaguars that's 50/50 pick'em Giants at
Cowboys the cowboy is favored by three
points and Seahawks at bears no no I
have now found my lock of the week okay
the New York Giants over the Dallas
Cowboys three points is so easy come on
that's the lock of the week so go to bed
TSA calm use punch 25 say Quan Barclay
throw 25 bucks on and on the lock of the
week and we'll see how many in how many
weeks it takes for me to be wrong this
week it is the New York Giants over
where's our UPS Dallas Cowboys they
could play on the hollow moon it's not
going to make a difference because that
[ __ ] is a wrap Dallas looks like garbage
Giants look good Barkley looks good
their offense I mean the Giants don't
have a great D but Barclays gonna be
able to [ __ ] make up for a lot of that
and Dallas looks like a dear confused
they don't know who they are anymore
dude they look they look in the mirror
and they think they're the Cardinals or
something they don't even tack who they
are exactly really bad man he has no one
to throw to well he was missing cigars
they got read a lot of throws they got
rid of Witten I think he's over in there
oh lines garbage how did that old line
go [ __ ] so quickly
remember they drafted so many linemen in
a row yep defensive line that's pretty
good I mean let's give him some credit
no no their line is bad though and
here's a big problem is that the way
that the collective bargaining agreement
has come uh it just makes it hard for
these lot the offensive linemen to come
together in the amount of time that it
takes to gel you know what I'm saying
like they they basically these guys play
its touch but until they've in the part
where darks de água playing touch but no
park with all those dorks it's very
quiet right now for Conor McGregor
fighting in three weeks I think I think
they're gonna camp it out he's pissed
cause he's not doing a lot of promotion
like they thought he would be there I
think don't amp it up in a little bit
you think I
think I mean we're still up almost a
month out you just watch Donner runs the
show Connor doesn't want to do it he's
not gonna do anything yeah yeah yeah I'm
Ally like no I don't need to do it
people are gonna buy it's gonna be crazy
dude they created a monster man they
created a [ __ ] monster
ah the UFC is ah like they fell up all
this like money that they're making for
me it's three weeks from Saturday it's
not based on their numbers aren't good
like the last fight night didn't do well
do you guys watch boxing this week I
know I did watch hearts there's a lot of
good fights Shawn Porter versus it was I
watch that wonderful in that heavyweight
fight on that Showtime core that first
heavyweight fight that was great come
back do you got okay so I think triple G
got robbed I do too I think I think you
really got robbed I think especially now
that we know Canelo was probably juicing
and like it's just like what do you
think we're stupid game I got some meat
with some steroids in it bummer
give me you don't worry I didn't I won
bill was like you know everybody's
[ __ ] cheating there they get it's
like that's exactly what Lance Armstrong
said that was his defense
everybody's chena I just got caught it's
like basically dude but it's true yeah
Wesley in that sport that's sport there
there been so many creative ways people
you know they found motorized [ __ ]
things inside of bikes yeah where you
just kind of can pretend to be pedaling
it's unlikely oh so you're on a
motorcycle basically yeah it's so crazy
it's like there's so much money in it
man anywhere there's money like that
people are gonna cheat yeah yeah find
that yeah and the reason Lance Armstrong
went down so hard cuz he treated
everybody like well no he won - that's
like the past that's the Pats were like
the Browns and just getting their ass
when the Falcons weren't a playoff
contending team and they were pumping
noise like instead of playing music
intercom they would pump noise in to
make the crowd sound louder when the
other team had the ball and they're like
that's cheating his [ __ ] it cost us a
six round pick no one really talked
about that because we weren't winning
yeah had we bit one four out of
five Super Bowls that would have been a
[ __ ] world war three right everybody
would have gone nuts
Iker who do you got in the triple G fine
I got triple G but Canelo does look good
well I'm worried triple G he's stuck he
started like he's getting a little slow
on down a little bit well they say he's
been destroying people and this could be
just a [ __ ] hopes up destroying
people in his trainers he's got to get
old sometimes I don't I I like if you're
like would you bet money on that fight I
probably wouldn't know unless I was a
fan of punk and then I go to bet dsi and
you could punch 25 but I'm sorry $25
junk sports double-reed alright look up
I mean it's hard for us too
it's hard for me to pick on it I mean I
literally if you could tell me four
different scenarios on that fight and
I'm like yep that could happen yeah that
yeah I line jumps in the ring and kills
everybody nobody gets now I don't think
anybody get out now I don't I don't
think there's a knockout that's the only
thing I don't I have the Lovings gonna
be pushing for one more this time just
because of the result last time but I
think it's gonna I think triple G I'm
going with triple G I thought he was on
that fight I think God and that's him on
roids
so we'll see dude I mean but then again
go you have to bet if you go you have to
bet I would say triple G I would say
triple team we don't want a bet on that
because Canela looks good and that dudes
tough man
he's had a draw and one loss to a
[ __ ] in his prime Mayweather yeah I
mean the two of the best fighters in his
weight division in the last decade and
he's a young dude I mean he's not 35 you
know Canelo yeah he's not 35 so you know
you look at his track record you like
damn you lost once to the best maybe
fighter ever
yeah well we got zoom in please welcome
the man greatest an atomic bomb ever
shocked the world first of all it's
almost like a rope-a-dope where let's
draw his team the worst team ever and
yet somehow against all odds wins his
first week against somebody who had to
drink piss yeah they like this guy drank
piss to get into this league and and
Chad
all he did to get Nazir on draft day
yeah and it has the worst draft of all
time how many kickers did you start this
week bro
I suck he's guys he's got two Cougars
he's sad are you there
I'm on the phone I am one in all [ __ ]
Ranas easy [ __ ] it
max Miller Nick Wilkins math building
Pinkley Joshua what Martin chases Tebow
you [ __ ] losers I mean I am NOT I
must admit I was laughing quite a bit
during your draft
I was dude listen to it as the podcasts
been put out yet will tonight it's so
good as we just [ __ ] destroy Chad for
his drafting is no Chloe's doing let's
look at his draft let's go so good we're
gonna pick buy pick now look what an
interesting strategy to go kicker Round
three
yeah when most people go I'm gonna use
my last pick on a kicker you're like no
I need a kicker now Chad correct me if
I'm wrong but your first pick was an
auto draft pick right yeah so that was a
good pick it was Melvin Gordon of the
two first picks was a kicker and then
Jarvis Landry Jarvis Landry in round two
that's all early for old jarv
and that was uh that was an auto no that
was him he that's a Cleveland Browns
first pick overall is the brown Melvin
number two receiver Melvin Gordon was
his first no no that was an auto-pay his
first pick his first pick was the Browns
number two Jarvis Landry there's slot
receiver yeah Cam Newton in the third
round you might say a little early there
quite Greg Suhr line the ramps kicker in
the fourth fourth round Rams kicker and
it's probably about 18 more rounds until
anybody else gets a kick yeah well no
but you should definitely shouldn't take
a kicker into like the last couple
rounds in round five he took Stephen
Gostkowski
two rounds later
[Laughter]
what was your thinking there Chad the
new way you can't have enough kickers I
say that all the time Ben Roethlisberger
in round six so now you got two
quarterbacks two kickers around would
you say he needs another quarterback in
round seven because he took one all the
course he took Philip Rivers in your
first six picks three quarterback
educators and I've been in a number two
receiver how great is that
the best draft of all time and then he
took Isaiah Crowell because he used to
play for the Browns took him in he had a
great game we really blew that up
tonio gates in round nine early for the
aging time now for Chad zoom I wasn't in
the NFL 20 days ago that's right
although he did have four points this
week Tyler Lockett the Seattle receiver
round 11 Ronald Jones Tampa Bay running
back John Ross the Panthers defense
Chris Godwin and he ended it with Chris
Ivory so really the first half is where
all the excitement is Wow
and how did he win what did the other
guy have Hey hey Chad what's your team
call the Cleveland say it out loud
you're gay and you're proud and he beat
the this is the team name so apologies
2017 champ drank my piss okay which one
were you apologizing for this the name
of the team was it the Cleveland [ __ ]
or the I drink my piss to drink my piss
that's what he wants apologize man
that's too many words that I the world
of punch drunk 131 13 - 104 he won that
got 23 points from koel man koel it
really good he look good the Jets looked
I know but I may be the biggest surprise
team of the week for me and say what you
want but Zuerlein is kicker 16 points as
week and that's what you do that's yeah
that's just in a different gear than
ever
rabbie kicker in round 3 and round 4
well 4 is just in case you know you
gotta have a backup those numbers for
the rest of the season that's not a bad
hand right if you get 16 points out any
player consistently that's not a bad
[ __ ] thing better my Ryan oh yeah too
soon too soon god he'll be alright
Chad does anybody want to trade for a
kicker
does anybody needs three or four
quarterbacks cuz uh how did his
quarterbacks do this let's see I mean
dude Chad you might make some trades
yeah I could do could you I think
Campbell you know was just like okay you
had a rushing touchdown cam at 17 that's
not Philip Rivers 35 did he start Philip
Rivers no he didn't use it oh my god Ben
Roethlisberger had 13 he started yeah
you might want to drop him dude might
want to drop him check him I was playing
the brown he's looking old man Chad did
you know you research on fantasy
football are you just gonna go straight
gun on this thing no I I did when I did
the lineup I did my research I didn't
work I did some googling to be fair to
Chad he only found out about the draft
like an hour before it happened so we
were did he know he was in it well yeah
he did an hour before the draft I want
to make this about sexism hi you know
I'm [ __ ] Serena Williams know who
anyone was like we were like holding a
contest like an hour before the draft
people are rolling hot dogs across
Walmart oh yeah oh I gotta I gotta show
you guys that video yeah that was great
oh yeah he did that yeah you can date it
I'd rather do that then shove it up my
butt no this is probably got a couple
things up your butt so you're not
worried you two had a couple things this
morning
dude I took a [ __ ] so good today that I
started believing in America
again that's how good this [ __ ] was it
was such a good [ __ ] speaking of
believing in America again
how hilarious was it that during the
first half of the first games Trump
started tweeting the NFL ratings are
down 13% their season is so bad the
ratings don't come out for like a day or
two later
that's impossible he would have ratings
before the first game is even over oh
it's impossible you would have ratings
not the President of the United States
he has access to area 51
oh yeah you think that guy thinks that
much about that shinri point Ari and if
that does if that's true if that's what
he's doing is spending all of his time
and resources to keep trying to [ __ ]
with the NFL I mean I would have done
time and resources by tweeting no are
you saying no he went out of his way in
the first quarter of footballs but the
NFL has been on for 17 minutes okay I'm
not give you an impression of Trump
spending all this time getting the NFL
but hello somebody get me the ratings
both that's done boo guys no there's no
way that's even possible he would know
that [ __ ] yeah dude he knows everything
oh yeah oh yeah trouble knows everything
yet another politician in the pocket of
big Nielsen what is it here we go okay
was he in the wall no he rolled it the
first time the first time was a solid
roll okay this is it and he's doing it
all the way the he didn't have to do it
in the bag really went man he went
really I think he enjoyed this I hope
this guy wins the league and then dies
we haven't heard from him he's dead okay
here we go shove it in your ass
I can't even watch I'll throw up I'll
pull around of these okay we donut that
you ate this is gonna bother you that's
not gross you guys I love you I love I
love a has a Lance Armstrong oh my god I
love exercise looks like eat food off
yeah yeah I mean that guy's definitely
ate out of cousin before so I think
eating a hotdog
I think mitch is like a hair or
something to look at this guy he's great
that guy loves WrestleMania for sure you
know it's a pubic hair that guy has
every x-men comic book yeah yeah yeah
that guy jerks off to porno cartoons
that's my point okay good he's doing
this in a collared shirt like the Geico
caveman just [ __ ] put in work now
Xena hot dog because he's a grown-ass
man with hot dogs like just a cold hot
dog might make me go I think he was
keeping in his Park just say a cold hot
dog would make you gay gag she starts
eating snatch out to that okay he's
great
good for him thank you for being a true
American Hero
oh that's a good point well he lost in
the video but let's see how he did in
fantasy that's I know he doesn't have
four kickers I can guarantee ya what are
you doing dude it sounds like you're
what straining [ __ ] are you doing I'm
listening to the conversation I'm
hearing a lot of like you get great
opportunity dude you're like me on Dada
I just did the Church of what's
happening now and I literally just sat
there that and listened the Joey Diaz
and Eddie Bravo tell stories I mean it's
kind of hard to get in with those two I
mean I I preferred it dog one time I was
living under a spaceship I know you were
living under a spaceship yeah you know
those Rockets in in a park I go oh you
were homeless in a park that's totally
different then I was living in under a
spaceship I don't know what this get you
know what Joey Diaz the story literally
said when I was last time I you would
have to try to live an adventure every
day your life and he's done that every
day I'm
I'll know how you got all these stories
Phil it's unbelievable he's only up
there like 85 like he's still got a
couple decades to go it's unbelievable
right I mean I just got like oh my god
you did all that I'm out of stories I'm
uh you know the crab feast is coming to
an end and they're like who they're
gonna be that they got ten episodes loud
they do that baseball thing yeah yeah
who won that Jay Larson yo neither of
them hit it is a home run like they said
they were gonna but by distance j1j went
322 yeah that's still pretty good if he
had an aluminum bat he'd had done 350
they all want cheating aluminum's not
cheating cheating did it that aluminum
bat in major leagues pitchers would die
yeah there'd be four deaths a year I'm
fine with that I'm I'm too I think they
should have assault rifles I think they
should have catchers should have assault
rifles and if they can kill you while
you're stealing yeah that'd be great I'd
say release animals during the
seventh-inning stretch whether they guys
dies and landmines I say landmines would
make baseball way more interesting oh is
this mine I show you in the top of the
seventh oh the home-field advantage is
that the animals go out there we go
there we go guys big announcement I'll
be in the belly room at the comic store
Thursday at 7:30 so thank you sponsored
no come on that's uh no still be up so
uh grab lunch grab dates at spoiler
alert not yet but I have some big ones
coming
okay what about I thought you had like a
those Ark statement okay I did that the
other day
you don't watch that show I literally
can't hear anybody this is the happiest
I've been in a very long time yeah this
is good audio - yeah anybody
cool man I'm enjoying this unfortunately
we can hear you Hillary Hillary Clinton
Jason Bateman dies in the last episode
guys anyway anyway
Chad yeah finally it's 20 minutes ago
hey Chad we're trying to what rap is up
Chad what do you think about LeBron
James as a Laker right now don't say it
don't say it hang up on him now I love
it I love the fact that he left
Cleveland to go to LA are you kidding me
aren't you thing about going to LA he's
gone oh [ __ ]
that's our fans 100 a blonde talk
everybody wants to hear but LeBron you
know the worst thing about it is this
there's about 80 days a year where I
don't have to hear about the Lakers and
all during those 80 days LeBron has made
me hear about the Lakers yes I don't
know what I'm gonna do when Bay
basketball starts but this will be the
year that I hate the NBA and they're not
gonna be that good and we're still gonna
have to watch it's gonna be the worst
it's gonna be the worst what are your
thoughts on Khalil Mack going bananas we
look good ah I am okay with it
two sacks forced fumble interception for
taco in one hey real quick did Chicago
win the game I'm not talking about that
I'm so an individual game without him
they wouldn't win the game did the word
I mean like Chicago win the game with a
question you didn't see the game would
you have in Chicago win the game if you
did that to the Rams would you guys have
won the game no how do you know that no
the answer's no I know thank you thank
you dude that wasn't cool point that
wasn't the question
idiot but that's the answer it might not
be the question you're answering asking
but it's the answer I got on that why
you don't pay that guy that much
what about paying a coach 10 million
dollars a year dude I'm fine with that
you agree I would say yeah dude after
that about that coach he got the same
amount of money he got the same amount
of money kilowatt got right over 10
years no he got less money oh yeah yeah
okay
a hundred million dollars I mean how do
you feel about him now
uh-huh I mean like dude I wasn't happy
what happened now what I'll tell you is
that doesn't count against the cap yeah
so if they're like in but the Bears are
teaming I have all that money waters
have all that money fine but dude but
you can your argument is the bills left
all that dead money on the table yeah
the Bears had the same amount of dead
money and they spent it on the best
defensive player in the in the NFL and
they still lost
they were gotten smoked if it wasn't a
diet coke getting the [ __ ] loss is a
loss I mean so then in that same
argument then you're fine with your
coach giving him a hundred million
dollars because oh how come he didn't
get out coached ah a duty dude if you
gave Gruden the same talent that [ __ ]
what it what's-his-face has it would be
a different game man what's-his-face
I met whoever the coach of the Rams is
okay okay but if you give Cleo Mack on a
team uh-huh
that is already [ __ ] like dude worst
we got out we got car getting all this
money right it's gonna be impossible to
build that defense with one guy eating
up all that [ __ ] yeah right okay so
the coaches thing doesn't count chords
towards this [ __ ] system that we had
to put in place because either some guys
spend too much and they'll out like you
got Dallas well I'll spend everybody
just like in baseball the the Yankees
can outspend anybody the Dodge can
outspend at everybody so they have a
salary cap so there's like the socialism
and in the NFL so every market can
compete right if you give that guy that
big thing that defense will never get
better so my whole point is what most of
the Raider fans have been saying to
really look at this it's like Cleo Mac
can go to [ __ ] off and you still lose
and that was my point and he went off
and they still lost it has that his
fault it's the it's [ __ ] the Havas
matter it doesn't matter so he said what
if the Raiders would have won though
maybe I'm just saying dude we had him
and we couldn't stop anybody we couldn't
stop anybody so whatever it is he had
the greatest season ever if they lose
what's the [ __ ] point he shouldn't
even try yeah just trade all your
players and if you have the Bears
defense and fantasy
that's pretty good for you okay that's
great maybe Chad drafted the Bears I
don't [ __ ] know but the point is they
paid them all that money they lost their
that fantastic young defense all right
they do I mean they're lying back in
court is insane it's the same way
they're so young that they could afford
to pay the two years ago MVP who's super
young prime of his life all that money
and a lot of the big free agent signings
went off Commack earn that money
[ __ ] cousins earned that money you
know all of these big fries and
sightings were like goddamn they paid
that dude a lot of money not a free
agent signing but how good in my home's
look did you see I'm in all my legs
the Chiefs look wonderful because the
the charters I mean I think they're
pretty solid right and you just Tyriq
Hill is a [ __ ] monster yeah all you
got to do is get that guy the ball and
it's through Chiefs probably win that
division charge is good though charges
don't sleep on the charges but they
don't have a [ __ ] fan base to save
their lives
Tyree kills seven receptions 169 yards
two touchdowns and nine and don't forget
a punt return and also a 70 yard punt
return he had three touchdowns and
probably 250 yards and they won by 10
and he accounted for 21 of their 38
points that kids special great player
fast as [ __ ] that Barkley look I know
you like sick one Barkley he look really
good for the Giants Barkley again oh I
mean one run take that one run away and
it what were his numbers 18 for 106 and
a touchdown and 60 of that was a
touchdown so he would have 17 for 60
Beckham 11 for 111 17 for 40 he would
add 17 carries for 40 yards on that one
in Mero Jerry Sanders remember people
would say like dude you [ __ ] shut him
down for a half and then the second half
he just my job it carries it always have
one or two big carries and the rest
would be like two yard or two yarders
two yards 40 yards way to move to Clyde
such a weird career in where's leaving
like that I get it Detroit
yeah it's like you're an app it's like
your owner is everything I remember in
Madden for like five years after that he
would be a free agent that you could
pick up like just maybe you'll come back
really yeah Adrian Peterson was like
that too after its spanking
he looked pretty good he did look good
yeah he's still got some life left you
would think after all those knee
surgeries had a touchdown and why you
just one of those dudes just built for
that could built play forever
yep you know yeah you can't there's no
predictability about it you know I mean
maybe Serena Williams that she's just
like a juggernaut yeah and she but she's
playing like he said at 28 they start to
fall off she's ten years after that yeah
I mean start to follow up she's a beast
and she had a baby in January yeah I'm
yes I mean look what baby's done to this
I mean she's [ __ ] quitting on
everything you guys did have our skier
she pulls up if there's no parking she
drives home she has no heart anymore she
just gives up you guys see the cartoon
Oh
Syrena yeah that one that everybody says
a bracelet it just kind of looks like
her right I mean that's the everybody
saying it's like a like dude she looks
like nobody Ali I'm including your
sister it doesn't look anything like her
sister they look like they used to look
exactly alike
now she looks I mean look at it it's
hard to do a caricature of Serena
Williams and have it not I missed those
old buck uniforms oh those creamsicle
yeah those are great there's a lot of
good lucks going on having a good game
dude dude you know what everybody says
that uh here's this cartoon Renee you
know Renee the door guys distort that
how much it looks like Johnny Manziel
are you think that's racist that cartoon
it's racist
what do you mean whoa well the guy the
guy does caricatures of people and
they're saying this is racist she those
older who do math okay hold on everyone
just takes things out of context like
it's like the only thing anyone's ever
done is the thing they're mad about I
just love that somebody who has been the
top of her league and has made so much
money that just now it's like oh man
she's just been victim of racism it's
just like makes no [ __ ] just look at
this this is these are white people
nobody gave us
about this yeah yeah yeah that's racing
yeah I don't show that's racist yeah
that's anti-gay cuz there's a rainbow in
it got there's a rainbow in its anti-gay
the guy just exaggerated features that
is that's his style
yeah [ __ ] him [ __ ] her man she okay I
like Serena I likeable I mean like dude
she destroyed her sister her sister I
mean destroyed their this remember when
Venus Williams was the talk of the town
for a little bit yeah big lips I guess
so yeah yeah you know huge ass and you
just heart like I mean I mean look at
that what is the the referees but other
umpire or whatever is supposed to be
well at you he's got a big nose that's
what I'm saying they're like what are
you where we making fun of people with
Roman noses now no that's this guy's
style the guy's not [ __ ] you just
think he's a [ __ ] Jew because the
judge because the judge because he's got
a big nose for a lot of reasons for a
lot of reasons Oh him yeah what are you
[Laughter]
well you know like the Williams sisters
got it so that the female players get
paid as much as the man and that sounds
like oh that sounds like equality until
you realize that the females play way
less games
oh good boys 3 to 5 that's not equal
that's actually special you getting paid
more to do the same job why do they play
less because they're females
that's literally what are the guys play
how many guys play five the women play
three and those five do could go five
hours I mean there much longer sets when
women do have longer rallies though at
least I mean women's tennis is just as
interesting as men's you know one of the
strike and watch and be like that was
[ __ ] awesome because they keep the
rallies going for
that's gotta be it has nothing to do
with know that that's a big part of it
dude what do you that's that every
that's it that's widely accepted that
the reason why miss tennis is
entertaining that's why everybody always
sat there it's not like Pete Sampras
going out there with a taste every time
what what do you think it is this is
this you disagree but you don't have any
opinion chicks and skirts bra okay no I
mean the play though like what if you
default I said my pom-pom oh yeah this
is back what else have we talked
baseball I loved you I'm gonna be on the
right [ __ ] garbage I supported the Simon
Wiesenthal Center did you watch a UFC
nanny no you didn't you just followed
online or something what do you do what
do you guys do when you can't watch it
you sure dog like the play-by-play okay
you didn't watch it right you guys you
go and read it all this their streams
are all on reddit but then we watched
afterwards we watch like the Jessica
Andrade that was not it was like a
minute we watched that minute and then
that is a wall that is a fighter
fighting a chick I mean that you see the
way they're built yeah I mean it's just
you know what man it's like when you see
like super feminine men you're like okay
that is that girl is that they just have
a super build and dude
this girl's like a little cyborg they
have the same built just she's a tiny
version of yeah she's and she was just
beating this chick like she spilled her
beer during the Super Bowl was already
on the card because she wasn't her
original opponent so I'm confused
no her original opponent like had to go
to the [ __ ] I know but so did this
girl take the fight in a day or was she
wanted them no this was a different that
was a different way class that was a
lower weight class so the other girl
didn't get to fight no oh and they
stripped that chick of her title
all right you that okay but like she
never even defended it or anything
yeah no weight class
has to be something up with this wake up
because why would they strip you so
quickly yeah that's a bad PR move there
must have been something more to the
weight club because polish chick they
just send her up to get her ass kicked a
lot right though that guess she like
she's been beaten soundly a couple of
times that dude on the left looks pissed
she really tripolis haircut thank you I
did not had a good way I'm how do you
Woodleigh one like in a more exciting
fashion than he normally does because he
gets [ __ ] on so much for that yeah yeah
yeah so I'm glad that he did that I just
say I think tells a great fight I just
don't think that he's ready for that yet
he's only like 25 26 that tattooed on
that guys are paid fancy lots of bag of
bats he look like he will also a drew
had to drop so much weight to get to
that that weight class I just feel like
he was drained too are you going any
Yankee games I'm gonna go to the playoff
game down the road almost entirely and
then when they are here I'll be on the
road but I'm gonna go to the plan game
if they get home field it's their three
games right now
to Oakland they might even get home
field for the playing game right this
whole season they there right now
they're the second best record in
baseball and they got a [ __ ] play one
game playoff with no real shutdown ace
who are they gonna who would they pitch
sorry for this the one game playoff
what's his name Severino Tanaka no no
don't pitch to not gonna pitch I go
Tanaka every time is he around every
time I say I say hi Cohen and I say
goodbye more Asian when they're on stage
too Tanaka or Ali Wong who gets my Asian
women
no who gets more Asian like the Asian is
well I think Aiko is just naturally more
Asian yeah I'm gonna say her accent the
the shift is probably more Ali Wong yeah
cuz I cause just that already like he
doesn't get more age
she just is the same thing Ali Wong you
talk up seems like hey Ali she's like hi
how are you what's up nothing goes on
Sage I just walk I got I just get got
one rickshaw but who is this nope
nobody's with me on that one okay all
right she should do one of your comedy
classes yeah but she won't let your
stalker
Severino Tanaka Sabathia Happ and then
Lance Lynn Dozier yeah I don't know how
you could play him in that game I mean
he's played well but I don't know how
you play him in that game no that's
tough man it's Severino may be Tanaka
you're not gonna put Sabathia because
you know he's not go past five or six
innings dude I love fat guy pitchers I
root for them yeah me too I love them
it's fat men do you don't like fat
fighters but fat pitchers you're okay
with no they're a little fat when they
come in with pure [ __ ] tits that pisses
me off
there's you draw a line yeah I just like
it's like dude you're supposed to be an
athlete like like a ball guy like the
same ER a it's kind of weird right the
ranch look at him now you're right like
Cain Velasquez do you think it's tits
no but I do believe he could be he I
believe he could get to 205 if he really
want it might be hard now he's older I
don't think you to 205 I totally believe
he can get the two I saw back in the day
and be effective in the Octagon for sure
Oh
Cain Velasquez yeah I saw him and John
Jones standing next to each other John
Jones said their tenures a different in
age right back when I saw well the other
so buddies yes younger when I saw yeah
yeah like I said today now he may not
you mean yeah at some point in time in
his career he could could go five guys
whoa wait a few an RA fight will you try
that make a catch weight no can you get
to the same way no no he's making me
fight at 240 re can you get to 235 it
was a great special special episode I
think we learned a lot about each other
we had some great Collins
we had some guy who heavily cuz he was
in a writers room
mmm Chad gloated I mean it's all
together that really short enough face
that guy yeah called are we going God
what'd you say alright you really threw
it in our faces success yeah I mean if
there's one thing we learned we are all
green and we don't know [ __ ] about
writers rooms I have a great 911 Ari
final thoughts on your easel and what
they did to us our proudest achievement
wolf goes down is one of the greatest
Jew moments in history along with Sandy
Koufax no-hitter rebuilding the first
temple was there that's it Oh Einstein
Ari do you feel you're getting more
chewy as you get older what's like your
right guys we'll see you next week
next week we have hot chicks who are
fighting each other coming in oh yeah I
couldn't do it this week because it was
a special show I guess so next week
they'll be coming in hot strippers who
box each other will be in so we'll get
to see Johnny he's autistic ass pop
boners everybody we will see you all
except boner very soon and see you next
time bye everybody see in Canada suck my
dick